you know lisa ayat you know joseph yeah
lovely lee's the best
he's not going to new jersey with joe
right i don't think he is
but he is he that little fat guy that
eats crazy amounts of weight
yeah he's like 400 pounds now he got
bigger he's 5-1 too
which is which is especially impressive
someone's telling me he's like really
heavy now but uh
how can you say really heavy now like
what was he before
i'm talking like my 600 pound life tlc
oh [ __ ] yeah he told me he was like
dude i think he's like 300 400 pounds i
went no dude the video that's the nicest
guy in the world
he's like i met him before because he
hangs out with telly but i saw him
on diaz show when he ate all those
stuff when his brain broke it was the
funniest weed thing i've ever seen
that's a guy that smokes a lot of weed i
don't think i've ever laughed more at
someone
that high but yeah this one but he might
but he also looked like
asleep he also looked like he could die
right now like he looked like he's
serious have you had yeah
yeah and then if you're telling me he's
now 600 pound
and he still might eat one of those
stuff i'm not sure if he's 600. somebody
told me
have you seen lee lately he's got really
heavy okay 400.
bro if he's that's dead honestly and
make your
like get your heart real oh my god oh my
god dude
that looks like the end of scarface
where i'm like please yeah i'm almost
about to say mama he's hilarious but he
he smacked me into like reality
um because i was going through this
thing where it's like i gotta keep
trying new things new things new things
and it's like
everyone knew things and regard to what
professionally all right
and i was like nothing will make me
learn how to like
tighten up my my wit than stand up
because the stakes are so high
because i started doing stand up you
know and uh i was not
great but i was i wasn't bad you know i
think i had potential to be
something but i would go out and do a
set like
three times a week when i was really
balling it up and one night i was doing
when lee was performing i was doing a
set there and um
i showed up and i was like man yeah you
know i'm really trying you know this is
like the the third second time of this
week that i got
and he's like oh man that's awesome you
know you're doing really well yeah i
just came from an open mic in santa
monica after this i'm gonna hit up uh a
place in the valley that i know has an
open mic
and he's like yeah i try to get up like
three or four times a night and i was
like
oh oh that's that's what it means to do
it and i
and then it hit me it hit me like a ton
of bricks i was like oh no
stick with what you're really passionate
about and go for it and don't like
don't try to load yourself you can't
really half-ass stand up yeah
not saying you're half-assed no no i
wasn't like that's what i was
i was i was half-assing it in in
comparison to the stuff that means
something to me where
especially when i was young i had no i
had nothing nothing you know and people
gifted me this insane opportunity to be
on the radio
i didn't [ __ ] sleep and when i was
not on the air i was
actively thinking about more [ __ ] i
could do to get on the air more
like and and like that's not how i was
with stand-up that's not how i am with
personal training or whatever you know
what i'm saying if you're not it's hard
when you're
older and you've got all these other
things in your life just to just be
you know to do four different sets in
one night yeah
but then get up and you know with your
child
at six in the morning it's totally true
stand up and kids
i'm like what because you guys are all
up late but if it lit my fire if it lit
my fire
i could do it and my wife would
understand you know what i'm saying like
there's times with
with like my animated show um
where yeah i just i just will work for
12 hours not even
needing to it's just like me and having
these meetings over like the
scheme of yellow that we're gonna be
able to put into with the
and i'm sitting here with the animators
and time just flies by it's because like
i can't i can't fathom not investing
myself
to that level um and i still go home to
my kid i still go home to my wife you
know what i'm saying like if you
if you needed me to do something for the
jason ellis show if we had like a giant
bit to pro or like the wrestling thing
yeah like whatever whatever happened
whatever needed to happen was gonna
happen
you know like and that's because it lit
that thing inside of me and
i think we all lie to ourselves with
trying to do things that we're not
really that passionate about if you're
not passionate you can get random man i
wish i was more passionate about comedy
than mma because
i don't know about my true comedy
talents but i believe that i could be
okay handle the job if i was like you
said as passionate as i am about
mixed martial arts at 48 with no
ligaments in my legs like
i'm gonna have another fight i wanna
pitch scott coker i'm like you should
really shut the [ __ ] up and play
scrabble but when i get off stage at the
lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son